foreign
welcome back to CBS morning's and a
lawsuit against the Department of
Defense bringing new attention to an
issue we've been reporting on for years
now veterans being exposed to toxic
chemicals at bases overseas the focus of
this lawsuit is the base known as K2
it's an Uzbekistan at least 15
000 service members have passed through
that base it was in support of U.S
missions in Afghanistan and now veterans
are suing the department saying public
records do not explain the high rates of
rare illnesses that they're experiencing
for several years our senior
investigative correspondent Catherine
Herridge has been speaking to some of
these service members many of whom
revealed rare Cancers and other serious
illnesses all of them pass through K2
and all of them are now looking for
answers and Catherine Harris joins us
now from the Pentagon this morning
Catherine good morning to you
Good morning Tony these veterans and
their families told CBS news they served
with honor and they never imagined
they'd have to sue their own government
for answers
he said to me my head is about to
explode I can't talk about this I can't
talk about this deployment and I thought
oh my gosh what is happening to my
husband I don't I I cried Kim's husband
Lieutenant Colonel Tim Brooks was among
the first soldiers deployed overseas
after 9 11. she says he never showed
fear until one day in 2002. and he said
that he had had a briefing and he says I
was just told I was exposed to some very
bad stuff and the thing that I remember
from that is I heard uranium
Tim had just returned from karshi
khanabot or K2 a former Soviet Military
Base in Uzbekistan used by American
forces to hunt Al-Qaeda terrorists in
neighboring Afghanistan
in 2020 a CBS News investigation
documented evidence of toxic conditions
at the base including soil saturated
with jet fuel and warnings about
chemical agents and radiation after
deploying to K2 Tim was diagnosed with
an aggressive brain cancer
it was a battle
I was a battle
Tim Brooks died in 2004 leaving Kim a
single mother of four was it at that
point that you wanted answers
I never stopped wanting those answers
it's the color that cuts you Pam
Enlisted the help of her daughter Megan
Brooks a supervising attorney at Yale's
veterans Legal Services Clinic I think
more than anything my dad really valued
um doing what you can to take care of
others and that's sort of how I see my
own work exhibit with the help of
Megan's team of law students K2 families
sued the defense department this month
for records about toxic material at the
base military doctors told us many
others had been affected that Tim wasn't
the only one the lawsuit alleges the
missing information prevents K2 veterans
from obtaining accurate medical
diagnoses and adequate treatment plans
and it is honestly shocking and
unconscionable that the requests have
just been ignored bounced around the
Department of Defense not prioritized
what difference will the records make
that's the difference between knowing
what happened to you and being in the
dark military surgeon Gordon Peters was
deployed to K2 he says he witnessed the
potential health hazards firsthand we
found this field scattered with enriched
uranium partially enriched uranium
yellow cake I mean it literally it was
just aerosolized and we took Geiger
counters out there and it made lit up
these images shared with the K2 veteran
appear to support Peter's account
multiple sources say they were told
yellow cake was identified at the base
though there is a dispute about its
potency so this has been known to the
defense department for 22 years
yeah so um
it's tough to see it
it actually really is following a spill
at a base bunker in 2003 CBS News has
learned an environmental team at K2
found traces of hydrogen cyanide a
poisonous chemical agent though its use
was unclear defense secretary Lloyd
Austin then a Commanding General was
briefed on that incident according to
records reviewed by CBS News Senator
Richard Blumenthal has voiced support
for the lawsuit and promised to seek
accountability I will personally take
this fight
and this issue to Secretary of Defense
Austin for Kim and Megan their fight is
about countless others there are
veterans right now like Mark Jackson was
in the hospital with his fifth or sixth
in surgery for an infection that just
will not go away and they don't know the
cause of it we need answers our veterans
need answers now
a defense official told CBS News
Environmental Health site surveys are
already Declassified and studies into
the health effects are ongoing the
official called the yellow cake claim a
mischaracterization the official did not
address the 2003 briefing to General
Austin about hydrogen cyanide but
pointed to other reports that did not
identify chemical warfare agents a
spokesperson for the secretary said care
for veterans and service members is a
top priority Tony
Boy you know you serve your country
overseas you come back you think you
have your health and then this seems to
come for you these allegations are very
serious and I know you'll stay on top of
it Catherine thank you very much